because we mentioned
the concept so much and a lot of people
know it
but can you say what computational
reduceability is yeah right so
i mean the question is if you think
about things
that happen as being computations you
think about
the uh some process in physics
something that you compute in
mathematics whatever else it's a
computation in the sense it has definite
rules
you follow those rules you uh follow
them many steps
and you get some results so then the
issue is
if you look at all these different kinds
of computations that can happen whether
they're computations that are happening
in the natural world whether they're
happening in our brains
whether they're happening in our
mathematics whatever else the big
question is how do these computations
compare
is are there dumb computations and smart
computations
or are they somehow all equivalent and
the thing that i kind of
uh was sort of surprised to realize from
a bunch of experiments that i did in the
early 90s and now we have tons more
evidence for it
this thing i call the principle of
computational equivalence which
basically says
when one of these computations one of
these processes that follows rules
doesn't seem like it's doing something
obviously simple
then it has reached the sort of
equivalent level of sophisticate of
computational sophistication
of everything so what does that mean
that means that you know you might say
gosh i'm studying this little tiny you
know tiny program on my computer i'm
studying this little thing in
nature but i have my brain and my brain
is surely much smarter than that thing
i'm going to be able to systematically
outrun the computation that it does
because i have a more sophisticated
computation that i can do
but what the principle of computational
equivalence says is that doesn't work
our our brains are doing computations
that are exactly equivalent
to the kinds of computations that are
being done and all these other sorts of
systems
and so what consequences that have well
it means that we can't systematically
outrun these systems
these systems are computationally
irreducible
in the sense that there's no sort of
shortcut that we can make that jumps to
the answer
now in a general case right right but
but the
so what has happened you know what
science has become
used to doing is using the little sort
of pockets of computational reducibility
which by the way are an inevitable
consequence of computational
irreducibility
that there have to be these pockets
scattered around of computational
reducibility
to be able to find those particular
cases where you can jump ahead i mean
one one thing sort of a little bit of a
parable type thing that
i think is fun to tell you know if you
look at ancient babylon
they were trying to predict three kinds
of things they tried to predict you know
where the planets would be
what the weather would be like and who
would win or lose a certain battle
and they had no idea which of these
things would be more predictable
than the other that's fine and and you
know it turns out
you know where the planets are is a
piece of computational reducibility that
you know
300 years ago or so we pretty much
cracked mean it's been technically
difficult to get all the details right
but it's basically
we we got that you know who's going to
win or lose the battle
no we didn't crack that one that one
that one right the
game theorists are trying yeah and then
the weather
kind of halfway on that way yeah i think
we're we're doing okay at that one i
you know long-term climate different
story but the weather
you know we're much closer on that but
do you think eventually we'll figure out
the weather so
do you think eventually most think we'll
figure out the local pockets in
everything
essentially the local pockets of
reducibility no i think that the
it's a it's an interesting question but
i think that the you know there is an
infinite collection of these local
pockets we'll never run out of local
pockets and by the way
those local pockets are where we build
engineering for example that's how we
you know when we if we want to have a
predictable life so to speak
then you know we have to build in these
sort of pockets of reducibility
otherwise you know if we were if we were
sort of existing
in this kind of irreducible world we'd
never be able to
you know have definite things to know
what's going to happen
you